okay so there was your answer now here
was my question to you
i asked a whole bunch of you and i never
really got a super confident answer
okay what we did was if i pedal back to
here okay if i write this out uh
without sort of simplifying just keep it
in general terms what we've really done
is this
you've got one integral from a to b and
then you square
each function independently
so you've got y squared and then you've
got y the other y
squared and then you do the whole lot
with respect to x that's what we did
okay but my question was
if we come back to this which is saying
it's about an area and that area is
rotated
why is it that we don't compute the
volume the same way you do an area if
you did the area
right you'd go pi sorry not pi this is
an area
you go a to b of square root of x that's
the bigger one
one on the square root of x then you do
that
okay now if i apply my normal volume
equation
volume formula to that you stick a pi
out the front and you square it
okay which is not what you did
and it would give you quite a radically
different answer okay
my question is number one why does it
give you a different answer
number two why is that answer wrong
maybe number three what answer is it
gives you because it's giving you
something meaningful
it's just not that okay all right let's
go number one
uh why is it wrong why is it wait was
that my first question
yeah why why is it wrong
well you say okay squaring the whole
thing but why not square the whole thing
like that's what a volume does you sweat
the whole thing whatever y
is in this case it just had to be very
simple but if it had more stuff in it
you'd square the whole line
so why is squaring the whole lot bad
here
let's just give it a go let's see what
happens so you'll get pi
one to four okay what do you get in here
because we we can deal with this a
squared
plus two a b plus b squared so that was
x
minus two plus
one on x okay now just compare that
to what we actually integrated
right and you're like that's totally off
that's completely different
okay why is it completely different
this is difference of squares isn't it
okay
this is the square of a difference right
it's the square of a difference and
they're not the same thing
okay now how can you convince yourself
that it's this one and it's not
that one think carefully this is the
at the point at which no one could give
you a good answer okay and it was
probably because
you didn't have your volume drawn that's
a big clue
how can you look at this thing and tell
me of course this one
what were you smoking when you wrote
that right look at it with me
the reason i come back to this is
because you can see from the diagram
it's one volume minus a whole
different volume the volumes i'm
thinking of them completely
independently
hear that completely independently
they only come together because they
happen to have the same constant
coefficient and the same operator
bounds what you do here is no longer
treating them as independent
you're mixing them together and then
you're taking a volume
that's confused so number one is wrong
number two the reason it's wrong is
because the two volumes are
actually totally different guys okay
that's why you compute them separately
we just so happen to notice that
algebraically you can do them together
all right bonus question
what volume are we working out
what is that void
because you know what it's almost on my
diagram it's almost there
now remember i gave you some um
some dodgy arguments before for why this
was right
i said look this is the area that i was
asked to do
and this is what happens when you turn
an area into a volume
okay i am actually working on a legit
volume
what volume is it
it's it's the volume defined by this
area
but what's the difference
now of course i could say it's a
different graph
sure it's a different graph but then
again says this this is also a different
graph
okay it just so happens that that graph
is exactly the same one
as the ones that i want okay but this
one is not
what what
the difference here is this will give
you the area sure enough
but it will only give you the area it'll
only give you a shaded in black
it'll only give you this thing okay
now what this has which this lacks
is that see this gap here
where did this gap come from it came
from
considering the two volumes
independently
but when you stop thinking about them
independently all you have
is that area that area
what's it look like
this distance here do you know what it
is that distance then
it's a heart okay so that distance
should come down to
here so if something like this that'd be
no that was one before so actually
should only come up to about
a half it should be shallow okay then
that comes up to well this came up to
two before
didn't know so this would come up to
about zero a half
one something like that
there's my area there's the area i
calculated
there and now i do what this does which
is
rotate the thing like so
oops it's upside down here we go
and there's the car in the middle
that's the area sorry that's the volume
we just worked out
because it's that area rotated around
that axis
okay but you lose that data
when you forget about thinking about
them independently
okay so that's why it gives you the
wrong answer it gives you the right
answer to a different question
does this make sense now
you need to be able to reason that
yourself like i said this
is pretty easy numbers the diagram's not
too bad either
okay i hope we've rammed home enough
right that when you get something that
is lifted off the axis
you'll end up with this hollow volume
how do you evaluate it
you consider the two volumes completely
separately
one two okay which as a side note is why
it's dangerous to just memorize formulas
like that
you just memorize that you're in trouble
because you're like oh
wait did i square them first what did i
take the difference and then square
okay the formula kind of obscures it
right
that's why it's kind of like well this
is not a shortcut it takes longer to
write but the
reasoning is clearer just makes sense